Alex Rodriguez dishes on his ladylove
Jennifer Lopez she's great she's fun and
they're intense workouts well Jennifer
always kicks my butt
the jet-setting couple made a stop in
Minneapolis for Super Bowl weekend on
Saturday night they hit up the true
fusion pop-up at the wheels up party a
rod is an investor in the fitness
facility he opened up about taking
classes with JLo well Jennifer always
kicks my butt but she's a great dancer
she loves it as well look I think the
combination for me is a hybrid of
Barry's bootcamp and yoga and hot yoga
and I think the fact that you can work
on your flexibility your strength your
core and do it in a group environment
it's great when the couple isn't working
on their sculpted bods Elrod says they
keep it low-key
we just like to keep it simple anything
with the kids anything with a movie
chocolate chip cookies you know she's
great
she's fun and like we say she's like
everyone's boss around here
it's really max and I and we have the
ladies are crazy the governing body at
the home and with Valentine's Day right
around the corner
seems like a-rod has something romantic
up his sleeve well I started a while ago
but I'm not gonna share that secret with
you man but it's gonna be good
[Music]